you mentioned 12 hours is that something
you also spend gina like what what have
you ever i'm out
eighteen twenty four i mean there are
days when it's
24 um you know if i'm on a deadline
um tip when i'm writing
you know let's see let me just do the
math i'm not
you know 12 13 hours is pretty common
when um deep in a script or when i'm
researching
you know because i put a lot of research
in to things
because i get attracted to a topic i
know nothing about they're
usually all girls like i did kabul
beauty school
it didn't have a great fate because
um you know no one's gonna make that
movie but i
i was really late in handing it in um
because i'm not that educated i knew
nothing about
afghanistan and um
but i was it's all i thought about
at day and night was like burqa chicks
you know and
you know normally you're given three
months to finish a script
you know three maybe four you know um
not that anybody's ever gotten mad over
four or five i mean you know that
depends on how badly they need it
but i was like oh gosh a year and a half
you know to hand it in the first draft
because it was
yeah it's a different world so yeah i
spend a lot of time
um you know now um um
i'm not writing right now so you know
i'm reading and watching movies and
playing with my friends